What is tracking, and is the job of being a director a job to protect?
Well, I am a director myself, but in fact,
it is very difficult to ask this question.
It's such a question that's not easy to answer more
.
Pico How Development October n His
understudy If I get asked a question like this during an interview, I'll sneak
away and I'll always avoid or run away, but today I asked that question.
The directors say they don't. I'm talking about Laska's Shinzo passer-by n, you
know, I'm here about the twisted server of summoning.
What would you do if you were to briefly explain
this g20 superman? I sent you a question like this. Recording room Moas Abbie Hap book Spain Mr. Carand who got rid of
it Tony at the event wedding Boa who has sprouted up Dare 3 5 Gubo Let
's listen to the answers from people who are very impressed  It
's nepa cooked school s antenna fire isd fis something can't be substituted
For Pomos Winterberg, directing is like jumping off a cliff on which my own building slides.
It is said that a
certain passionate sense of solidarity soars when everyone jumps together with others.
Director Lia Zak-jeong says films should be a response to life,
not the other way around. To create a story that can truly reach people,
storytellers  must be rooted in our real life
Directors Glow Wee Left and Right, who have peeled off the shells that define us and transcribed the experience of seeing them from the perspective of others, say directors are people
who know how to do a
lot of
things, but have never mastered anything properly.  At the beginning, while watching a movie like The Darkness of Dreams, I
ask myself
what would director Werner Herzog do in a situation
like this.  When the
director of Emerald was 8 years old, when his mother asked him, “What do you want to be when you grow up?”, the first
thing he said after hearing about a kid was “I
want to write a murder story.
”
When you're filming a scene for a scene, there are hundreds of ways to do it, but in the end,
you know there's only 2 ways. The
right way and the wrong way.
I'm going to announce the winner
Andy Awkward Stu
Chloe 4 5 Listen to it over ahhh
[Music]
Uh
a
cao ne next thank you thank you 2d fornication a
raw q horse playon side by side so i su by lur family is this stem too
my in car 10
noma liver company ol creze this enemy is on horseback,
thank you for chasing him  fuzz yu
um r peri way up awai quick goo why are you holdings almar
anal ding so watermelon i.e. plastic surgery logo or 5th century
one house up venture mother another child spy ds game memorized
is kasec shiny star wars mdx snacks  In other words, 8 n between us,
even if we contact each other, propaganda player Ender will be summoned, we will be summoned.
Anal Import & Export 1 Jesus Altar
This time, first of all, the times and do say something to Perth
9 9 But 3 4 know me without skin Use the tone while there is a pro
dr neon
order oreo Even if it is right, Slam South is still finished, so Chu
you, other East Both & soul spy
mitsuki gong thank you packing
[applause]